this rainforest can only be reached on
foot
jean titer and the ebel forest research
project team are on the lookout for rare
primates
oh look that's a gorilla's nest
they usually build them on the ground
after their evening meal they make
themselves a place to sleep
we have 11 primate species here
including gorillas chimpanzees drills
and prices red columbus monkeys
the primates are in high demand with
poachers who can sell them as bush meat
jaunty teal also used to make his living
that way but for most of the last 10
years he's only studied their tracks to
find out which animals are traveling
where in the forest
he lives in ibuti on the edge of abel
forest one of the three villagers that
are taking part in the project
i have grasped what impact poaching has
and anyway it's not really a profitable
business
okay yes you can earn a bit but the
income is very irregular that's why i
decided to stop hunting
usually now he only gets to see the
animals in video footage
the researchers have set up 17 trial
cameras in the part of the forest where
gorillas live
besides chimpanzees and gorillas these
forest elephants are also threatened
with extinction
and the extremely shy drills are
particularly at risk
the ebel forest research project was set
up by the san diego zoo wildlife
alliance which supports primate
conservation
it's been collaborating with the
villagers for more than 10 years
many of them used to be poachers
now they've learned to collect data on
the animals or set up camera traps
anyone who wants to take part must join
a guerrilla guardian club then they get
paid for their work
we have to thin out the clearing a bit
so the camera isn't obstructed
once a month the team spends a few days
venturing deep into the rainforest
they use compasses and gps to find their
way
marcel ketchen has been part of the team
for nine years
the environmental scientist records
precisely where each animal trail is
found
what's particularly interesting are the
movements of the around 25 gorillas that
were discovered here in 2002
up to then there were only two known
guerrilla subspecies in cameroon one
group living south of the sanaga river
and another hundreds of kilometers away
to the north
so the reason why we are collecting
these samples is to do some genetic
analysis
to find out where how related the
gorillas of able are
to those found out of the kasanagar and
the cross river gorillas it's very
significant and if it is if these
analyses are finally you know finally
come to a conclusion
we might realize that
in cameroon instead of having two
subspecies of gorillas we might be
having a third one
able forest in southwestern cameroon
covers an area of almost 1 500 square
kilometers and borders on nigeria
it is part of a large rainforest region
the second largest worldwide after the
amazon in brazil
to protect the rainforest in the future
the project aims to include the
residents of the more than 40 villages
surrounding the forest
the three villages taking part in the
project so far all have a guerrilla
guardians club
to enable the residents to feed their
families without having to resort to
poaching they can join the local club
here they get help to buy livestock or
plant vegetables or cocoa
joseph buckholic another former poacher
became a farmer almost a decade ago
he farms vegetables but focuses mainly
on cocoa beans cultivation
if he ever has problems he can get
support from the guerrilla guardian club
like all the other members
[Applause]
the cocoa plantation has changed my life
hunting is very tiring and you get
little money in the end
with the cocoa plantation i just have to
get up go to work and then harvest as
much as possible
[Music]
like here in ibuti there is a small
school in the other two villages on the
edge of the forest
the teachers receive training from the
scientists and protecting the forest and
its animals has become a fixture of the
curriculum
what kind of animal is that
[Music]
a gorilla ma'am
the idea is to raise awareness about the
topic among the youngest villagers
what i like about the course is the
gorillas
they are like people
and what i learned is that hunting isn't
good because animals are like people
the project has made many of the
villagers see the forest with different
eyes
like jauntiteer some 90 of the one-time
poachers have become farmers
and that's what the children see while
they grow up
but the guerrilla guardians clubs don't
want things to stop there
we want to know go zone to be created in
which the measures to guarantee the
survival of the gorillas are respected
because the species is in danger of
extinction
that's why he only takes his children to
the edge of the forest
look here this trail what animal left
that trail
a porcupine
wants his children to know about animals
but he also wants them to know when to
leave the forest to its inhabitants
you